"
♪ ♪
LET THE BLAME GAME BEGAN,
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS HOLDING OUT
HOPE FOR CONTROL OF THE HOUSE AS
DEMOCRATS RAMP UP THE INTERPARTY
FIGHTING OVER WHY THEY LOST KEY
SEATS TO THE REPUBLICANS.
THE GRAND OLD PARTY EDGING CLOSE
TO THE MAGIC NUMBER OF 218 FOR
THE MAJORITY AND THEY ARE STILL
CONFIDENT IT WILL GET THERE.
BUT JOE BIDEN SEEMS TO THINK
THAT THE DEMS MAY EKE OUT A WIN.
>> IT'S STILL ALIVE, IT'S STILL
ALIVE.
IT STILL ALIVE.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND WHILE
JOE BIDEN HOPES FOR A MIRACLE,
THE DEMOCRATS ARE KNIFING EACH
OTHER.
NEW YORK DEMOCRAT SEAN PATRICK
MALONEY IS CALLING OUT
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ IN THE
WAKE OF HIS EMBARRASSING LOSS
SAYING "THE LAST TIME I RAN INTO
AOC, WE WERE BEATING HER
ENDORSED CANDIDATE 2-1 AND A
PRIMARY AND I DID NOT SEE HER
ONE MINUTE OF THESE MIDTERMS
HELPING OUR HOUSE MAJORITY.
SO I'M NOT SURE WHAT KIND OF
ADVICE SHE HAS, BUT I'M SURE SHE
WILL BE GENEROUS WITH IT."
AOC FIRING BACK BY TELLING
MALONEY TO "TAKE SOME OWNERSHIP"
DEMOCRATS LOST SEATS IN FLORIDA
AND THEY THINK IT'S TIME TO GIVE
UP ON THE SUNSHINE STATE.
>> WE WON'T LOSE THAT BAD IN
MISSISSIPPI, THERE'S NOT AS MANY
ELECTORAL VOTES, BUT I THINK
THAT IT MIGHT BE BETTER OFF
LOOKING HARDER IN MISSISSIPPI
THAN FLORIDA.
I DON'T KNOW THAT.
JUST GOING ON A RIFF OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD, BUT IT HAS BEEN VERY
FRUSTRATING.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY,
ALL RIGHT, DANA, I WILL START
WITH YOU, SEAN PATRICK MALONEY
AND I HAVE BEEN INTERESTED IN
THAT RACE FROM THE GET-GO WHEN
HE WAS IN PARIS RAISING MONEY ON
THAT BALCONY, DO YOU REMEMBER
THAT, HAROLD?
I WAS REALLY UPSET ABOUT THAT.
>> Harold: YOU ARE A QUESTION
MARK >> Judge Jeanine: WE DID
ON "THE FIVE," YOU DID NOT READ
THE PACKAGE THAT DAY.
YOU PROBABLY WEREN'T ON, BUT HE
SEEMS TO BE BLAMING AOC, AND
SHOULD SHE HAVE DONE MORE?
>> Dana: TWO WAYS OF ANSWERING
THIS, SO SEAN PATRICK MALONEY,
HE GOT REDISTRICTED AND
BASICALLY OUT STATED A DEMOCRAT
AND COME IN AND LOSS TO A
REPUBLICAN HEAD OF THE
DEMOCRATIC COMMITTEE AND THAT'S
REALLY SAYING SOMETHING.
SO HE LOST AND IT'S EMBARRASSING
HE ALSO DID NOT DO WELL ACROSS
THE BOARD IN NEW YORK PROBABLY
BECAUSE OF HOW WELL LEE ZELDIN
DID BECAUSE THEY LOST MANY SEATS
IN HUDSON RIVER VALLEY AND
LONG ISLAND.
NOW, IF I WERE HIM AND I HAD
JUST LOST INSTEAD OF PLOTTING MY
NEXT POLITICAL MOVE, I WOULD
TAKE A FEW DAYS OFF, GO ON
VACATION, MAYBE GO BACK TO
PARIS, JUST TAKE A MINUTE BEFORE
BLAMING OTHER PEOPLE, I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU ARE MAD, BUT
MAYBE THAT SOMETHING YOU DO
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THAT AOC'S RESPONSE TO
HIM WAS PRETTY GOOD.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, SHE WAS
COMPLAINING ABOUT RAISING MONEY,
$250,000.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE COMPARATIVELY
HOW MUCH THAT IS IT'S A DROP IN
THE BUCKET, NANCY PELOSI CAN
RAISE THAT IN 10 MINUTES, BUT
BECAUSE AOC IS BETTER AT THE
SMALL DOLLAR DONATIONS LIKE
BERNIE SANDERS OR EVEN MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE, THAT'S HER STRONG
POINT.
I WOULD SAY THAT'S COMING YOU
REMEMBER WHEN I KEPT SAYING
WHERE'S THE SQUAD?
THEY WERE VERY QUIET ALL SUMMER
AND ALL FALL THEY WERE HIDING
BECAUSE THEY KNEW THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO BE BLAMED AND NOW
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO BE
EMBOLDENED IF JOE BIDEN RUNS
AGAIN WHERE EVEN IF HE DOESN'T
COME OF THE SQUAD PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE --
WHAT ARE WE CALLING THEM NOW?
THE TYRANTS, THEY WILL BE MAD
AND VERY LOUD.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW,
YESTERDAY, HAROLD, WE TALKED
ABOUT THE SQUAD NOW HAVING TEN
PEOPLE IN IT AND SO THEY WILL BE
STRONGER AND LOUDER THAN THEY
WERE BEFORE PAIRED BUT TO GO
BACK TO SEAN PATRICK MALONEY, HE
BLAMED HOCHEL.
SAID THAT AT THE TOP OF THE
TICKET SHE SHOULD'VE BEEN
HELPING, SOME OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATES IN THE
HUDSON VALLEY ALONG WITH HIS
RACE AS WELL.
I MEAN, DOES SHE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY?
>> SHE IS A GOVERNOR, SHE WAS AT
THE HEAD OF THE TICKET, BUT THE
FIGHT IS HAPPENING EVERYWHERE,
THE FIGHT BETWEEN MALONEY AND
AOC HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A LONG
TIME, I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
LOVE LOST IT JUST DID NOT OCCUR
OVER THE LAST 22 HOURS,
EVERYBODY SHOULD TAKE A LESSON
FROM THE CAMPAIGN.
DEMOCRATS PROBABLY SHOULD NOT
OVERREACT EVEN THOUGH IT WAS A
GOOD NIGHT FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEY COULD
END UP WINNING OUTRIGHT MAJORITY
IN THE SENATE IF THE VOTE COUNTS
AS IT LOOKS LIKE IT IS GOING TO
WILL LEAD TO THAT.
TWO, THE PROBLEMS IN THE COUNTRY
DID NOT GO AWAY BECAUSE
REPUBLICANS DID NOT SCORE THE
VICTORIES THAT THEY WANTED OR
THE SIZE OF THE VICTORIES THEY
WANTED.
WHAT THE COUNTRY BASICALLY SAID
WAS WITH YOU LIKE, BOATERS
FORWARDED THE WOMEN VOTED FOR
THE POISON THEY KNEW AND ON ANY
NEW POISON, DEMOCRAT OR
REPUBLICAN, LOOK AT THE
GOVERNORS, IT WAS A GREAT NIGHT
FOR RON DeSANTIS, AND MICHIGAN
WAS A GREAT NIGHT FOR DEMOCRATS.
THE GOVERNOR WAS REELECTED, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS REELECTED,
THE SECRETARY OF STATE, THE
HOUSE IN THE SENATE, MICHIGAN
FLIPPED.
A LOT OF STORIES THAT HAVE COME
OUT OF THIS.
IF I WERE REPUBLICANS, WHAT IT
WOULD BE MOST CONCERNED ABOUT IS
WHAT IS IT THAT THE COUNTRY DID
NOT FULLY TRUST TO GIVE US THE
ABILITY AND THE CAPACITY AND THE
TOOLS TO HELP FIX THESE
PROBLEMS?
AND TWO, THEY NEED TO SET OUT
SOME OF THEIR LEADERSHIP ISSUES
AT THE TOP OF THE TICKET, BUT
THE PRESIDENCY.
AND DEMOCRATS NEED TO FIGURE OUT
OUT, THIS WAS NOT AN AFFIRMATION
FOR THE SQUAD OR THEIR POLITICS.
THE COUNTRY BASICALLY SAID THAT
THOSE ARE TWO PAR TO THE LEFT OR
THE RIGHT, WHEREVER YOU MAY SIT,
WE WANT YOU COMING BACK TO THE
MIDDLE.
AND IF YOU DON'T COME BACK TO
THE MIDDLE, WE ARE GOING TO PUT
YOU OUT.
WE CAN LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
GOVERNOR RACES OR REPUBLICANS
WHO THOUGHT THEY WERE FAVORED OR
HAVING A HARD TIME, WE'LL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS IS THE VOTES ARE
COUNTED.
BUT I'M JUST GLAD THAT THE
COUNTRY AND THE VOTERS, I'M NOT
SURPRISED, BUT I AM RELIEVED AND
HAPPY THAT EVERYBODY SEEMS TO
HAVE ACCEPTED THESE OUTCOMES.
AND WILL NOW SORT THROUGH AND
TRY TO GIVE SOME COMMENTARY.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS DID NOT AFFIRM
THE SQUAD'S MESSAGE AND
REPUBLICANS DID NOT TRUST YOU TO
FIX THE CHALLENGES.
SO IF I WERE IN CONGRESS I WILL
ROLL MY SLEEVES UP AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO WORK WITH THE OTHER
SIDE TO ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE
PRESIDENT SAID THAT HE WAS
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE OTHER SIDE, BUT IS THERE
ANYTHING IN WHEN YOU DOES -- HAS
DONE TO INDICATE THAT HE IS
WILLING TO DO THAT?
>> Will: NO, ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO SUGGEST THAT THERE
WILL BE BIPARTISAN PROGRESS
GOING FORWARD, I APPRECIATE WHAT
HAROLD SAID THAT THIS IS NOT AN
AFFIRMATION ON THE SQUAD OR THE
LEFT AGENDA, I DO THINK THERE IS
A BIT THIS WEEK TO HEAR FROM
DEMOCRATS AND PRESIDENT BIDEN IN
PARTICULAR WHERE THERE IS AN
ATTEMPT TO CLAIM SOME VICTORY.
IT'S TRUE THAT REPUBLICANS
PERFORMED BELOW EXPECTATIONS,
BUT THAT'S A BIT LIKE THE LOSING
FOOTBALL TEAM BRAGGING ABOUT
RECOVERY, DEMOCRAT SAYING THEY
HAD SOME VICTORY, WE STILL LOST
POWER BUT WE COVERED THE SPREAD.
IT'S A BIT OF A LOSER'S MESSAGE,
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THEY NO
LONGER HAVE EUN UNILATERAL POWER
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
>> WE NOW KNOW THAT FOR A FACT.
>> Will: THAT'S A FAIR CAVEAT.
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE
EXPECTED.
AOC IS AND INTO GRAHAM
INFLUENCER, EIGHT TIKTOK STAR,
HAS NO INFLUENCE ON POLICY OR A
NUN ON THE POLITICS AND HAPPENS
TO BE ONE OF THE BIG STARS OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY ALONG WITH
TWO TIME LOSER STACEY ABRAMS AND
THREE-TIME BETO O'ROURKE.
>> Dana: DON'T FORGET CHARLIE
CRIST.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW IT
IS INTERESTING, GREG, THERE SHE
IS, THE STAR OF THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY, AOC, AND YET SOMEONE, MAY
HAVE BEEN IN MALONEY REFERRING
TO HER AS A GHOST IN WASHINGTON,
NOT FIGHTING FOR THE MAJORITY,
AND IRAN'S STATE LAW AND LOST TO
ANDREW CUOMO, I DID NOT SAY A
WORD, JUST KIND OF LICKED MY
WOUNDS AND JUST MOVED ON.
YOU SHOULD NOT BE MOANING ABOUT
THAT STUFF, BUT YOU EXPECT THE
PARTY TO HELP YOU.
>> Greg: WHAT IS INTERESTING
IS SHE IS COMPLETELY IGNORED HER
CONSTITUENTS AND NEW YORKERS IN
GENERAL WHEN IT COMES TO THEM
SAYING THEY DON'T FEEL SAFE.
SHE JUST DID AN INTERVIEW, WHAT
DID SHE SAY?
SHE DID NOT FEEL SAFE.
IT WAS AN INTERVIEW WITH
CHRIS WALLACE AND SHE FEELS THAT
SHE CAN'T WALK HER DOG AT NIGHT.
AND THAT'S TERRIBLE FOR ANYBODY,
BUT IT IS TERRIBLE FOR
EVERYBODY.
SO NOW SHE UNDERSTANDS HOW HER
CONSTITUENTS AND HOW PEOPLE FEEL
IN THE SUBWAY AND MAYBE THAT
WILL GIVE HER A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMPASSION FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE WORRIED ABOUT IME.
EVERYBODY IS BLAMING EVERYONE,
WHICH MEANS IT'S PRETTY GOOD
OUTCOME, RIGHT?
REPUBLICANS ARE BLAMING TRUMP,
TRUMP IS BLAMING FOX, MALONEY IS
BLAMING AOC, AOC IS BLAMING
CAPITALISM, MSNBC IS BLAMING
WHITE PEOPLE.
I BLAME BRIAN KILMEADE, DANE IS
CLIMATE CHANGE, IT'S THE WILL OF
A RICH RELATIVE, EVERYBODY IS A
LITTLE DISAPPOINTED IN A LITTLE
BIT PLEASED, BUT YOU LEFT, LIFE
GOES ON, THE BRIGHT SIDE IS
NOBODY IS REALLY HAPPY AND THE
ONLY REASON WHY JOE SEEMS HAPPY
AS HIS EXPECTATIONS ARE LOWER
THAN HUNTER'S MORALS, SO IT'S
EASY FOR HIM TO ROLL ALONG.
RATHER THAN WRITING OFF FLORIDA,
WHY NOT ASK WHAT CAN BE LEARNED
FROM FLORIDA, WE HAVE --
STATES ARE BASICALLY THEIR OWN
INDEPENDENT EXPERIMENTS, RIGHT?
YOU CAN SEE RATHER THAN
NATIONAL, THAT'S WHAT --
OF COURSE, SO WITH COVID AND
HURRICANES, WHAT STATE DID
BETTER IN DEALING WITH
EMERGENCIES?
YOU CAN SEE IT IS FLORIDA.
SO WHAT CAN YOU LEARN ABOUT
ESTATE THAT DOESN'T HAVE THE
LAYERS SLOW-MOVING BUREAUCRACY
VERSUS BEING A FREEDOM LEANING
STATE AS OPPOSED TO ONE THAT IS
RELYING ON THE TYPE OF CONTROL
OF GOVERNMENT?
THAT IS SOMETHING YOU COULD LOOK
AT FLORIDA AND GO, HOW DID THEY
DO THIS?
RATHER THAN JUST SAYING --
THAT'S THEIR CALIFORNIA!
WHAT HE IS BASICALLY SAYING,
THEY ARE GOING TO WRITE OFF
FLORIDA OR NEW YORK, BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT'S COMING YOU KNOW, WE
ARE COMING BACK.
I WOULD SAY THAT THE RIGHT IS
COMING BACK IN NEW YORK AND WE
HAVE A LOT TO THINK TO ZELDA AND
FOR THAT AND THAT'S ALL I HAVE
TO SAY, JUDGE.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT'S
ENOUGH.
COMING UP NEXT, PRESIDENT BIDEN